As you seem to have noticed, in the “Humpty
Dumpty” nursery rhyme, nowhere does it say
that Humpty is an egg, yet he is often presented
as such in pictures and stories.
The version of the rhyme that most children
learn today goes like this:
Humpty Dumpty sat on a wall,
Humpty Dumpty had a great fall.
All the king’s horses and all the king’s
men
Couldn’t put Humpty together again.
The first known publication of Humpty Dumpty
was included in Juvenile Amusements by Samuel
Arnold in 1797.
In that version, the last lines read “Fourscore
men and fourscore more / could not make Humpty
Dumpty where he was before.”
Over the next century, the rhyme appeared
in numerous books with variations on the lyrics.
These publications did not include the first
use of the term “humpty dumpty,” though.
According to the Oxford English Dictionary,
“humpty dumpty” was first used in the
17th century and referred to brandy boiled
with ale.
In the 1700s, it was also a term used to describe
a short, clumsy person.
It has also been a nickname attributed to
someone who has had too much alcohol (perhaps
imbibing the drink of the same name).
As the popular nursery rhyme is neither a
bottle of alcohol nor a person, it is most
likely that the nursery rhyme was intended
as a riddle.
The answer to the riddle, of course, is “an
egg”—something that, if it rolled off
a wall, could not be mended by any number
of people.
Today, the answer is so well known that the
character of Humpty Dumpty has taken on the
appearance of an egg and the rhyme is not
considered to be a riddle at all, but a story.
Because of this switch from “riddle” to
“story”, many people today believe that
there is more meaning to the nursery rhyme
than is given in the lyrics.
Perhaps, in this instance, we could take advice
from Humpty Dumpty himself, as seen in Through
the Looking Glass by Lewis Carroll: “When
I use a word, it means just what I choose
it to mean—neither more nor less.”
People will always attribute more meaning
to nursery rhymes than was initially intended.
Nursery rhymes are commonly linked to historical
events, but it is difficult to prove that
imagery in the nursery rhymes represents historical
places and figures.
Most modern rhymes, after all, are created
with the intent of being silly, repetitive,
and enjoyable for children to repeat rather
than for their historical significance (think
“Miss Mary Mack” and other clapping games).
Two of the most popular theories link Humpty
Dumpty to two separate historical events.
The first is the Fall of Colchester.
During the English Civil War in 1648, the
town of Colchester was under siege.
Supposedly, a man named Jack Thompson was
stationed on the walls with a cannon nicknamed
“Humpty Dumpty.”
Thompson and the cannon managed to do a lot
of damage to the advancing Parliamentarian
troops, until the cannon eventually tumbled
to the ground.
Given the size and weight of the cannon, the
dozens of men who attempted to lift it back
to its place on the wall were unable to do
so.
Eventually, Colchester was forced to open
its gates and surrender.
While the siege of Colchester did happen,
it is unlikely that Humpty Dumpty refers to
anything in the siege as it happened over
a century before Humpty Dumpty was recorded
and there is no documented connection between
the two.
The other popular theory is that Humpty Dumpty
represented King Richard III.
, called the “humpbacked king”.
(He supposedly was a hunchback, though recent
evidence seems to indicate Shakespeare was
wildly exaggerating on this point, with Richard
actually apparently having scoliosis which
made his right shoulder higher than the left,
but otherwise no hunch).
In 1485, Richard III fought at the Battle
of Bosworth.
In this “humpty dumpty” origin story,
it was said that either his horse was named
“Wall” or his men, who abandoned him,
were representative of the “wall.”
Either way, the king fell off his horse and
was supposedly hacked to pieces on the field—thus
no one could put him together again.
Several problems exist with this theory, the
least of which being that the term “humpbacked”
didn’t exist in King Richard’s day, nor
for several centuries after.
(The term “hunchback” also didn’t first
pop up until the 18th century).
Much more importantly was that the king’s
remains were recently found largely intact
save for a bludgeon to the head which probably
killed him.
Additionally, other than pure speculation,
as in the previous “siege of Colchester”
theory, no solid historical evidence has been
found that shows that King Richard III was
the inspiration for Humpty Dumpty.
And, indeed, one of the reasons it’s so
often connected, because of the “all the
king’s horses and all the king’s men”
bit, as noted, wasn’t even in the original
version, being the more generic “fourscore
men and fourscore more”.
The historical events that have been linked
to “Humpty Dumpty” provide excellent stories,
but are based on pure speculation.
Given the actual evidence at hand, it is far
more likely that Humpty Dumpty was not intended
to be a story, but rather just a riddle posed
to children for their amusement.
The answer to the riddle, as stated, is “an
egg”, which is why Humpty Dumpty today is
nearly always depicted as such.
The first time the character of Humpty Dumpty
was represented explicitly as an egg was in
Lewis Carroll’s Through the Looking Glass
in 1872.